What has fans complaining the most about
"Wednesday" on Netflix? It's not the acting,
or the story. It's a common problem
that a lot of streaming series have
been running into – and it looks ugly, literally.
Streamers have had a rough go of it lately
when it comes to fan reception to CGI
on a streaming-TV budget. The initial
responses to the CGI in the "She-Hulk:
Attorney at Law" trailer were so intense, for
example, that Disney did its best to quickly
and quietly improve it between the time that the
YouTube trailer dropped and the series debuted.
Now, Netflix is under fire for
the CGI in its new macabre series,
"Wednesday," based on the deadpan teenage
daughter from "The Addams Family."
"I'm failing to see the problem here."
OK, we'll explain. The focus of the criticism
for the Tim Burton-directed series has
been on the monster called a Hyde. It's very
Burton-esque, with its large eyes and sharp teeth,
but far from realistic. The "Addams Family"
movies from the 1990s were a bit campy,
so they weren't known for realistic special
effects. But Netflix's "Wednesday" is a
dark and more grown-up tale of murder
and prejudice. Its themes are heavier,
and fans seem to be disappointed that the CGI
didn't live up to that standard of realism.
Plenty of fans have taken to Twitter
to voice their frustration about the
show's effects. One even said they
were fighting the urge to turn off
the show because they found the CGI
so grating. Another begged Netflix
to increase the show's budget so that
they wouldn't have to stop watching.
Other viewers were amused by what they see as the
low quality of the digital animation. For example,
one admitted to giggling at how awful it
was, but still punctuated their tweet with
a skull emoji to express their disapproval.
Another wondered if the special effects were
"a goof," some shared poorly animated gifs to
show what they thought the effects looked like.
It wasn't all joking around, though.
One viewer suggested an alternative
animation method, one that Burton has been
associated with in the past, tweeting,
It seems that some fans would have preferred
that the monster be made with Tim Burton's
unique stop-motion style from previous
projects like "The Corpse Bride" and
"Beetlejuice" rather than trying to split
the difference between quirky and realistic.
Thankfully, there is one visual effect that
most fans agree couldn't have turned out better:
Thing, as portrayed by Victor Dorobantu. The
disembodied hand follows Wednesday around for
the bulk of her journey, helping her as she
unravels the mystery behind Nevermore Academy
and its many strange characters. All the while,
the visual trickery is incredibly convincing.
The official Netflix Twitter account dropped some
behind-the-scenes Thing photos featuring Dorobantu
bringing his beloved character to life wearing
a blue suit so he could be digitally removed
in the edit. Many fans took this opportunity to
shower Dorobantu and Thing with love. One wrote,
"Oh, Thing. You poor, naive appendage."
Another described Thing as the perfect
blend of visual and practical effects,
and one fan even admitted they were totally duped
by how the "Wednesday" team made Thing happen.
When it came to removing Dorobantu's
body from the scenes he appears in,
the VFX team did a fine job. But when it
came time to construct an entire Hyde,
many fans seem to agree that
they just missed the mark.